voilà plus rares de porsche ferrari
c'est pas très grave et surtout ça peut
se racheter
par contre les enfants et le mal que ça
leur a fait hellmuth ou dira si c'est
vrai ou si c'est faux el mout je peux
vous dire derrière ses lunettes il voit
tout beinheim tu peux arrêter de faire
ça il ya le ptr
[Applaudissements]
non sans rigoler ces normes
je n'ai pas là c'est énorme c'est énorme
le futur c'est à dire la vérité c'est
d'être écoutés bugs de jeunesse lui
almuth hellmuth est ce que c'est vrai
qu'il a pété à oui merci venise c'est
eux qui sont dans l'eau deux mois je
suis trop loin ça va ça veut dire que
depuis le début à la fin bonjour la voir
donc toi
ah ben c'est la vraie bonne mais c'est
la vraie voix c'est dominique duforest
la vraie voix la voix piscine cyclades
stories à une question pour qui
dominique et merci d'être avec nous en
tout cas
alors logiquement merci logiquement la
voie et nous vérifions taux bas jamin à
benjamin way2many y ait ce qui réjouit
les audiences de secret story bat ce que
de ton temps pour des pauvres si
lointaine les genres voici la question
de la voix te réjouis tue souvent du
malheur des autres
c'est tout pour le moment
[Applaudissements]
c'est chaud chaud chaud
alors attendez attendez vous allez
répondre merci la voie en tout cas
d'avoir participé dans mieux foutu la
merde et c'est la merde alors alors je
me réjouis pas du malheur des autres
dans quatre secret' je vous il ya une
chose évidemment que par orgueil on est
très content quand vous quittez une
émission les plus dans le programme que
l'une des choses que cela gueule
évidemment que ça m'a fait un plaisir
immense
oui mais je vous dis évidemment on n'a
pas envie et lille sont que vous avez
quittez vous survive je trouve que j'ai
quitté deux fois dans ma vie un afro
cram
j'avais quitté nouvelle star qui après
mon départ alors on a fini très bien
écrit gili après ça c'est que cela
figure et dans 4 6 1 c'est pareil alors
j'ai toujours dénoncé j'aime équipes du
programme ou de l'animateur est plus
fort mais le fait est que voilà donc
dans ces deux cas précis j'étais content
que après moi ça se casse la gueule
j'ai une question à vous poser ouais les
yeux dans les yeux ouais c'est toute la
vérité ce soir est ce que vous trouvez
christophe beaugrand qu'un bon animateur
dans secret story non
benjamin quand on a brassé comme toi
jusqu'à 100000 euros par mois qu'est-ce
qui a été le plus dur a lâché dont on
ancien train de vie à
spacex et montrant nu qui m'a lâché en
piste mais ça qu'est ce qui s'est passé
oh j'ai raconté beaucoup de poids mais
j'ai fait j'ai fait des mauvais
investissements jean procès avec une
banque l'oenothèque steira j'espère que
ça va bien se terminer je vais gagner
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous avez voilà
agefi grosses casseroles au cul ouais
ouais ouais
ah bah ouais et lui s'étaient fa lun non
le en fait ce qui est en fait ce qui est
le plus dur je vais très honnête c'est
que quand on voit qu'en fait quand la
merde arrive on se persuade que ça va
durer qu'un temps
on n'ouvre pas les yeux dans quoi
pendant un temps j'ai fait celui qui
voyait pas les meufs qui allait me
tomber sur la figure et ça m'est tombé
depuis que j'ai absolument tout perdu
donc ce qu'est ce qui est le plus dur a
lâché 2 dans son os un train de vie
c'est le regard de vos enfants qui ne
comprennent pas pourquoi vous pouvez
plus faire ce que vous faisiez avant
parce que le reste ce n'est que du
matériel et que finalement voilà une
bagnole ça ça se remplace
mais quand leur le regard de vos enfants
changent parce qu'ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi c'est différent et pourquoi il
ya moins de cadeaux et pourquoi et
pourquoi et pourquoi et pourquoi et que
ça devient avait aussi pour un vrai
traumatisme parce qu'on leur fait des
réflexions à l'école parce qu'on l'a dis
à ton père les blindes ares alors qu'ils
savent très bien que c'est plus qu'à ça
c'est ce qui est plus dur dans ce qui
m'est arrivé le reste honnêtement je
vais être je vais être franc voilà
fureur de porsche ou ferrari c'est pas
très grave
et surtout ça peut se racheter par
contre les enfants et le mal que ça leur
a fait c'est plus compliqué
[Musique]
qu'est ce que clem avait c'est vrai ça
m'a en tout cas tu sais quoi je peux te
dire un truc c'est que j'espère que ça
va aller mieux pour toi j'espère si vous
aimez rire il ya des gens plus
malheureux et et tu sais qu'en tout cas
ici donc lâchera jamais non mais c'est
vrai mon chef c'est à part de leurs maux
face à la question suivante